all right so as the 2024 presidential
race is heating up entrepreneur author
Vivek ramaswamy has announced this week
that he is running in the Republican
primary he came out of the gate with
some key policy proposals like a plan to
end affirmative action a push to
completely separate the American economy
from China and this week he has been
campaigning in Iowa New Hampshire where
he now joins us sir uh vivec welcome to
the program thanks for being here
thank you Sean thank you guys appreciate
that okay so I'm aware of you I'm you've
you've been I believe on my radio show a
number of times right
um yes but you're not well known to the
American people so you're going up
against eventually I think you'll be
going up against some of the biggest
names in the Republican party are you
running for name recognition or are you
really in this because you want to win
and you think you have a better Vision
than the people that are in the race now
Sean I'm in this to be the next
president of the United States and I am
running on a vision for our country that
I have developed over the last three
years this is not somebody else's Vision
this is my vision I believe we're in the
middle of a national identity crisis
where most Americans can't even answer
the question of what it means to be an
American today and I'm running for
president to revive the ideals that set
this nation into motion 250 years ago
basic ideas like Merit getting ahead
based on hard work and your commitment
and your dedication rather than your
skin color ideas like free speech and
open debate for settling political
differences the basic idea the most
fundamental idea that the people who we
elect to run the government are the ones
who actually run the government rather
than a managerial aristocracy that
actually runs the show today and I
believe that as president of the United
States I can deliver on that okay so
you're looking for the Republican
nomination
probably the leader right now would be
Donald Trump if you look at the polls
what are the policy differences you have
between yourself and Donald Trump
so first of all Donald Trump's a friend
I'm not running against him I am running
on a vision foreign
against him let's be honest okay well
here's what I'm running for our country
but here's but let's let's talk about
differences because I'm with you Sean he
was the OG of America first I'm taking
that to the next level with America
First 2.0 okay let's actually get the
job done which means dismantling Federal
bureaucracy instead of instead of
actually these managerial protections
and Civil Service protections I'm
proposing eight-year Sunset Clauses for
anybody in the federal bureaucracy if I
can't derive a paycheck from the federal
government as the next U.S president for
more than eight years I don't think
other Federal bureaucrats should either
I'm going to shut down federal agencies
earlier today I put out my proposal to
actually shut down the Department of
Education which should not exist that's
just the first of many government
agencies that I am pledging to shut down
as the next president I am dismantling
this climate religion we have been
addicted to a climate religion that
shackles the United States while leaving
China untouched so I think it's about
taking it to the next level as far as I
see it all right vivec we're going to
watch your campaign closely uh welcome
to the race and got a lot of time
between now this time next year people
will be voting all around the country we
appreciate your time hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else